all right
madison madison oh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
from tampa florida tampa and uh tell me
about your family you had both your
parents when you were a kid
um my mom um
and hurt my mom's um boyfriend at the
time
but then she got married so it was my
stepdad but my dad
um we were gone because he went to
prison
when i was like did you go to prison for
him
um domestic violence yeah and he was
he's an alcoholic
drink a lot how was your childhood
um i got moved out of my parents house
when i was 13
because my stepdad used to you know
molest me
and so my mom chose me to leave
and my step dad stayed so they put me in
foster care when i was 13.
and how were things after you went to
the foster system i would run away a lot
ran away to the streets and stuff
because i didn't want to
i didn't want to be if i couldn't be
with my parents i
i didn't want to be anywhere yeah you
know
and when you ran away from the foster
system where would you go
i would go like with pimps or
um with because pimps
they you know they were they knew how to
maneuver me
i was underage and so they knew how to
like
um keep me away from the police and
that's where
i you know wanted to be was low profile
so so sex work started early for you
and how about drugs were drugs part of
the picture back then too yeah
cocaine um crack
um
not not heroin just yet two of my
when i was 19. yeah who introduced you
to those drugs
the men the pants yeah
this was in tampa tampa um
georgia um and i mean
yeah we would travel all on the east
coast
and you came out to l.a at what point
when
i got out of prison when i was 23
um so it took
years 24 when i was 20 almost 24 i moved
out to cali what were we doing in prison
residue on a spoon
i got caught with residue of heroin on a
spoon
they gave me three years reason for that
was because
they put me on probation for three years
and i couldn't stay clean long enough
to pee clean so um they kept on
arresting me for you know um not going
to probation and stuff like that
so they um so they took me to jail and i
pulled the rehab card
so um but i ran away from to react i ran
away when i got to rehab
so um i told the judge i said i won't be
able to stay clean
if i'm not you know gonna
in a program or something like that and
so you might as well just send me down
the road so that's what he did
i did two years 11 months and i got out
when i was
24. so my winning when i was
right before right um before i turned
21.
so i spent my 21st birthday in jail
[Music]
and then you came to l.a after that yeah
eight months later
because i moved to indianapolis with um
my prison pen pal
he was like a father figure and so yeah
but i got on heroin um
when i was 19 which is a good thing that
i went to prison because that's when the
heroin um fentanyl epidemic came
and when i got out of prison all my
friends were dead
so it was kind of a blessing that i went
to prison
do you have any friends today no you're
just kind of on your own
and where do you live you're in a tent
do you still work for the pimp or are
you on your own no i stopped
messing with that since i was 18
but someone um there has been
um you know
people trying to get at me but i know
just to
brush them off
and doing sex work have you have you had
some guys that have
given you a hard time when you get
picked up get some bad experiences
no not really i think that's why i've
never been raped
because i go along with it you know and
i
you know if i feel like it's you know
bad or if i'm getting
to staying there too long and i feel
like he's going to do something to me
then i find a gateway to where i just
run away
you know when he's like when i'm not
near them
but other than that it's great i i go
along with it
so and today you're trying is what
today you're using heroin yes
so you've been arrested for
what kind of stuff for um gta
um taking my extra guidance
card but i returned it but they the
state picked it up
um and then i got when i was
17 i got six trafficking charges
um but they said that i was the youngest
ever in the state of florida to get
these charges
which i mean i don't know they were
offering me 30 years but
it took five years to um to beat it
uh i beat it when i was in prison um
so you were sex trafficking
yeah i was sex trafficked yes when i was
when i was a
young kid you know when i was younger
and so i thought it was normal
you know recruiting girls bringing them
bringing them on the team you know so
i thought it was normal i didn't think i
was doing anything wrong
and then when um when i had gotten a
little bit older
like um 16
then i had was staying in this foster
home for a little bit
and i had convinced my bunkie to run
away with me
and um so i was telling her my labyrinth
my lavish life you know so and she liked
it
so that's how i got her you know and i
was showing her how to do it
taking pictures and how to post and all
that stuff like that
and i ended up leaving leaving the pimp
because
he um he's trying to put his hands on me
you know
and so she didn't want to go anywhere so
i was like okay fine stay with him well
i called her the next day when i was
already
away from them and she's like f you
um i'm keeping all your stuff and
he treats me good that was the last
thing i heard about her
until like months down the road i found
out she gets caught up north
and because he's beating her and um then
she tells the police that i
if it wasn't because of me she wouldn't
have did all that stuff so that's what
made them charge me with sex trafficking
and procuring someone under the age of
18 for prostitution
which i could have been charged as a sex
defender because i was um i ran away
until i was after 18
so they drag fouled me so but she was
only like a couple months
like two months younger than me but
i don't know i was kind of [ __ ] but
i ended up beating it
so because they were off me 30 years but
my lawyer was like
no that doesn't mean it's not like i put
a gun on her head you know
i didn't make her do nothing you know
i could see if i like you know you know
it's just what i was taught and learned
to teach
so i thought it was normal you know do
you show up contact with your family at
all
my dad passed away when i was 18 from
overdose
methadone and xanax and my mom we don't
have a really great relationship because
of my stepdad
so how do you spend your days now what
do you do um
i go through town
[Music]
um i just love life really
i don't sleep until i pass out because i
don't know what's gonna like happen
and i just
i don't know i just
trying to figure out
like um where my life is gonna lead you
know
how do you living this life how does it
make you feel i mean do you get
depressed or do you get
are you scared a lot or
i'm not scared but i am like
lonely and like
really um naive
a lot of people like get over on me and
stuff
yeah it's very i mean skid row is just a
tough neighborhood for anyone that
someone in your shoes must be really
tough
do you think if you had better parents
you might have steered clear of this and
do you see the connection between the
childhood you had and
yeah yeah the the sexual abuse and the
drug use from your dad
just kind of led you into this yeah
i think if um that never happened
because it still affects me to this day
like i can't so now i can't move on
like i don't know
because of that
were you close to your dad no
um i got back i was he actually got
custody of me
when i was um 16
and right before i had ran off again and
um
and it was sad because um i was dating
boys you know and um i didn't want to be
around him much
you know because i was like dad you know
growing up you know
and now i think back and i feel like i
feel like
crap because like when i was younger
i was like daddy daddy you know
and when he got custody of me he
he thought of me like back then you know
so if it like
he thought i didn't like him or
something
i'm sorry
do you feel in some ways maybe you're
just like following the footsteps of
your
of your parents living similar
a similar life yeah my dad on my dad's
side is really bad because my
grandmother she was a prostitute
she got aids and um she passed away
and my dad um he lived a pretty
drug life but my mom she's straight
she's she's good she smokes pot
but she's a hard worker
how do you think living this kind of
life has changed you you've been doing
it for quite a while how old do you know
i'm 26 26
do you think living on the streets has
changed you
or can you not even see the other side
because you've been doing it for so long
yeah
that's all you've known since you were
14 37 13
is there anyone in your life that you
trust or i don't have anybody
i have no family over here because i
moved out here
um with a ex little boyfriend
but he was abusive so i had to run away
from him
but um other than that i don't
hang out with anybody i have people
acquainted
you know but as far as like close friend
where i can run
and talk to now i don't have anybody
like that and um
and that's it's bad on me because i
don't have anybody to talk to
and i keep it all inside
and then they'll like once i'm blooming
i'll just
have like a crying day you know like
because everything's built up inside
it's got to be very hard to do
it do you have children no no kids
where do you see yourself being in like
five years do you see yourself getting
clean from
heroin or i feel like there's something
um that this isn't in the end of it that
there's so much more
to you know life but the past year
i haven't been able to see my future
like i feel like i don't have a long
time to live that's when i
felt you know with this whole corona
going on
it like really added into what i was
feeling but i just i can't picture
i used to be able to picture it but i
just can't
i can't picture
the future you ever feel suicidal or
anything like that
um yeah but i don't
think on it you know like
but lately i don't know i don't really
think about
it it's gonna hurt i don't know you're a
survivor
yeah i am scared of death that's one
thing i am scared of
to die and living here on skid row
have you had some bad things happen to
you here no you haven't
yeah good for you you're lucky
i know um a lot of people like a lot of
big
big homies they pulled me on to the side
and they said
um the whole many years that i've been
down here you're the first person that
i've seen
able to walk on all the streets and i
don't know if it's because i'm a
tourist that's what i say um because i'm
not from here you know i'm from florida
but
i don't disrespect anybody i just walk
on the street
just like everyone else you know because
i
i thought about california this is what
i thought about california
and um that i wasn't going to be able to
wear this navy blue shirt
down the street you know that's how they
projected
what california was like until i got
here and then i'm like okay
it's pretty it's not that bad
do you miss florida
i miss the beaches yeah
what do you wish was different about
your life today
what do you think would help you the
most right now
what do i think would be different you
said
what do you like what would help you the
most right now
you're in a jam kind of living homeless
and addicted to drugs and
doing sex work for money and it's just
it's a tough corner you're in i'm just
wondering what would it
like if there was one thing that could
change things for you
what do you think that would be
did not have told my pastor about what
was going on at home
yeah dealing with that just is that what
the drug
drug use is kind of like numbing you
from that pain
i forgave my stepdad i just i haven't
forgave my mom because
she like
she doesn't believe me you know
and i wish um i could take like a lie
detector test
and give it to her and walk away and
never see her again
so your mom doesn't believe you
no and that's why i can't move on i know
it sounds stupid but
it's just reality which i feel
i feel like i'm stuck in that i'm just
stuck i haven't grew up i haven't
i haven't been just stuck right madison
well thank you so much for sharing your
story
i hope you hope your life gets a little
better i hope you figure some some way
off
off of skid row and get out of here
thank you very much
you